how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival at how the
light gets in aaaggghhh
tell all the truth but tell it slant
success in circuit lies too bright for
our infirmed alight the truth superb
surprised as lightning to the children
eased with explanation kind the truth
must dazzle gradually or every man is
blind Dickinson is making a point here
about the shocking nosov truth the
potentially blinding force of Revelation
and the need to slow things down so that
it easily dazzled humans can absorb
whatever is being told or shown them but
she's doing something else as well
she's sharing qisas resistance to the
idea that perche should have an
impalpable design on us she's seeing the
most moving memorable effective approach
to a subject it's not necessarily or
ever through the front door but through
the side door round the back through a
window down the chimney she's saying
that truth superb surprise could most
reliably be realized by methods that are
in themselves surprising not
ostentatious not flamboyant or show-off
fee but striking is an unexpected angle
slanting the great modernist poets of
the early 20th century elaborated this
lesson in extraordinary ways formal as
well as philosophical but I won't sleep
over them and come nearly up today
because we have so little time to oppose
it who in fact pushback against
modernism in all kinds of ways and who
made his interrogation of what is and is
not true an important part of the
process Philip Larkin the word true
echoes in his poems like a pulse in the
poem ignorance he wonders what is true
or right or real in our album tomb much
more Anne Arundel to much more famously
he asks whether the recumbent Earl and
Countess or to put this another way the
lying Earl and Countess prove are almost
instinct almost true
what will survival versus love in
talking in bed he reaches for words that
are at once true
and kind or not untrue and not unkind in
ambulances he senses the solving
emptiness that lies just under all we do
and for a second
gets it hole so permanent and blank and
true in a bad one of his last poems on
the last great poem he wrote when he
squares up to oblivion he admits there
is nothing more terrible nothing more
true than the fact they're going to die
and so on Larkins intention here I think
is to use the word true when a sense of
incontrovertible actuality that
accompanies it as a way to steady the
rhetorical ship of the poems to ask what
life is really like
with our illusions slipped away and our
fancy language and our sugary
self-deceptions but this of course is
not all he does Larkins poems despite
their interest in speaking plainly about
familiar things continuing to negotiate
between the so-called ordinary speech
and language that is more excited
symbolical and strange the language of
dark moons and high windows and leonine
light falls this doubleness which I
believe converts into the energy that
drives Larkins whole artistic effort may
not be so complete a commitment to
telling it slant as Dickenson wants or
to the negative capability that Keats
talks about also the forms of feigning
valid by Shakespeare in Sydney but it
breathes the same air and it has the
same end in view it is proof of the
necessity of contradiction and of
opposing impulses being reconciled it's
also something that takes us back to
what bothered Plato the question of
whether or not poems can be poets can be
useful and to the question of what role
they might play in our time when
politicians want to convince us that we
should live in a binary world of
alternative judgments when fake news
exists to confirm and hasten the process
at any cost
when proponents of what Stephen Colbert
calls truthiness insists that conviction
is more valuable than evidence
proponents that range from firebrand
shock jocks some Instagram poets I must
say and to answer Plato I want to insist
that of course poets can be useful they
can speak truth to power in
obvious and blazing ways they can write
satires that expose corruption they can
attack governments they can write love
poems that give other lovers a voice and
elegies that help people in grief to
mourn they can give delight as Plato
himself a liar's they can catch the
zeitgeist of any given time and in this
way contribute to our understanding of
history they can also whether seeking to
spell an exact proposition or not be
immensely useful in not being useful and
using language that holds an equal
balance of opposites in resisting or
submerging other kinds of rational
discourse in offering linguistic
playfulness metaphorical richness
symbolical density as alternative but
equally significant ways to understand
our experience and insisting the deep
sanity of being in at least two minds
and demonstrating in fact that feigning
and deconstructing things that appear to
be hard and fast and practicing
indirection are all an infinitely
superior form of lying and vital for the
good health of the Republic get your
tickets for the world's largest music
and philosophy festival how the light
gets in aaaggghhh